hallo mein name ist luca meine damen und
herren herzlich willkommen hier heute zu
einem neuen video auf meinem knie
zusammen mit sandra wollen wir von so
etwas lieber mann und ich haben uns
jeder seine tüte hier voll mit
gegenständen rausgesucht zusammengekauft
in der wohnung hier gesucht die
zelltherapie und ich werde gleich einen
gegenstand rausnehmen oder halt keinen
gegenstand rausnehmen und muss ja das
erklären vielleicht glücklich aber auch
im sander muss erraten ob ich bleibe
oder ob ich wirklich schon die habe okay
dann war den ersten gegenstand den ich
habe ist eine klopapierrolle eine volle
klopapierrolle letzten jahr 2004 ein
geschenk bekommt ich denke mal ich sage
einfach nein mein körper sagt mir dass
ich habe eine unterhose von der hier
von mirja die sache ist als wir die
ganze sache nie zusammengewohnt haben
hast du gesagt juli soll runterkommen
das kann sein dass es aber nicht sein
dass ich glaube du hast eine unterhose
weil jude die dir da gebracht hat das
sind die ganz sicher ja also sagen wir
der nächste gegenständen ich hier habe
es eine klopapierrolle
nein nein weil ich kein alter
wieso wir konnten sagte sowie ging es
halt nicht selbst loben
ich hab mir leere wasserflasche hier
nein man hat gar nichts gehört als dem
gegenstand gerade rausgeholt hat
ich zieh dich voller alter nächste
gegenstand den ich habe sandra ist ein
fahrzeug ein hühnerei den dinosaurier
also ich habe auf jeden fall busch und
gesehen dass ihr alle habt ihr es nicht
ich habe ein gameboy hier gameboy ja
hast so ich kann mich nicht vorstellt
das runde dieses sideboard geschaut und
da waren gehen wollte habe ich mir okay
dann war meine hilfe gegenstand den ich
hier habe ist ein tacker ich hab noch
nie in tucker bei euch gesehen ich
glaube ich habe sich vorab als alter
wein nächster gegenstand und hause von
dir immer sympathisch also du sagst du
hast neben der unterhose die ich vorhin
schon erraten habe hast du noch eine
unterhose der nächste g gestanden den
ich hier habe liebe freundin ist nicht
befreundet oder tarife gegenstand den
ich habe ist auf jeden fall ein thema
steuer was auf der fensterbank so ein
ding es hat deine mama ich glaube dir
nicht so salz streuen und es ist ein
lehrer also du hast mein nächster
gegenstand ist meine zahnbürste ich
sagen ja das alles nicht reicht nicht
der vorletzte gegenstand für dich hier
sandra ist ein tischtennisball ok
tischtennisball könnte sogar echt gut
sein weil wir haben bier punkt gezockt
ich sage einfach mal ja kontrolliert
worden was der muschel ist aus einem
schalter als mein nächster gegenstand
ist ebenfalls ein 5 1 fev geräten
doch es gab viele seiner der nächste
gegenstand von mir ist ein
tischtennisball moody's gerät geht ja
das ist doch kein echter gameboys das
kommt natürlich auch so die gegenstände
ich halte jetzt einen tischtennisball du
fix mein kopf malta mit deinen gedanken
das erklärt natürlich einiges nein nein
mein letzter gegenstand für dich ist ein
ohrring ja glaub ich du bist du dir
sicherheit dass ich länger
ja ganz sicher die ja es ist die fritz
ich hab selbst geworden kein haus und
bei 67 und geldbeutel derzeit würden an
der stelle ist heute wieder doch nicht
alles sein dass die jung gewonnen und
daher dass ihr euch dann wenn euch
gefallen hat ich gerne und in die
kommentare was er schreibt allemal was
in die kommentare
sander hat jetzt übrigens auch im kanal
und den brocken blogs hoch sanchez live
[Musik]